18h49 on est ok est ce que tu sais si
bien est ce que tu es au courant de ce
hockey japon rothé sur commande pour
certaines personnes c'est inné pour les
autres c'est souvent plus compliqué mais
ça s'apprend c'est même un métier
les orthophonistes peuvent apprendre à
leurs patients à roter grâce à une
technique que je vous dévoilerai tout à
l'heure mais avant ça on va répondre à
cette question que vous vous posez bien
évidemment mais pourquoi diable des
professionnels de santé apprennent à
leur passion à roter pourquoi diable ben
tout simplement pour leur permettre de
parler dans certains cas de cancers orl
il faut retirer une partie de la gorge
ce qu'on appelle le larynx et qui abrite
notamment les cordes vocales
après cette opération la trachée des
patients est reliée directement ici au
niveau du coup on appelle ça un trachéo
ce tome du coup l'air ne passe plus ni
par l'onu ni par la bouche et en plus
comme les cordes vocales ont disparu
impossible de parler puisque en temps
normal c'est l'ère des foules ont expiré
par la trachée ou produits les sons en
faisant vibrer les fameuses cordes
vocales
alors au passage les cordes vocales
c'est pas des cornes
y'a pas des angelots qui joue l'art pour
son vote grande
[Musique]
d'ailleurs on nie pas les cordes vocales
ont dit les plis vocaux voulait
peut-être voir à quoi ça ressemble
steven mon grand tu peux venir s'il te
plaît allez mon conflits locaux gens
voilà donc vous avez compris
pas de cordes vocales pas de paroles est
pas si on peut parler même sans cordes
vocales
il ya même plusieurs possibilités on
peut utiliser une machine qu'on appelle
un électro larynx que le patient se
colle contre le coup et qui crée une
vibration sonore qu'on peut ensuite
transformé en syllabes en articulant de
façon classique fait comme net gerland
ce qui dans south park électro la rgpp
dans my name is earl
[Musique]
on peut aussi avoir recours à un implant
phonatoire qu'une espèce de petit tuyau
qui relie la trachée à l'oesophage et
qui permet de donner de la voix en
faisant vibrer le sphincter oesophagien
avec l'ère des tours et oui on a aussi
un sphincter dans l'oesophage et vouloir
que les sphincters quand ça vibre ça a
tendance à faire du bon d'où l'idée de
la troisième technique qu'on appelle la
voix eux sauf la sienne
le principe est simple pour produire un
son vous fait vibrer le saintais roseaux
fabien rothé
si vous voulez puis vous articulé de
façon habituelle pour transformer ça en
mots vous parlez en rotant littéralement
moyens puisque vous êtes là et vu qu'il
est un peu premier dans titre de la
vidéo
je vais vous faire un petit tuto
allons commencer très important rothé
sur commande ça nécessite d'être relâché
détendu relaxe à la cool
aucun élève pause
bon ça se passe en trois temps temps un
bloc de l'air c'est à dire on faire
entrer de l'air dans la bouche sans
l'inspiré dans 2 on accompagne l'air
dans l'oesophage pour ça il faut rentrer
le menton dans le coup et crée une
pression à l'intérieur de la bouche en
serrant les lèvres si vous n'êtes pas
laryngectomie vous avez encore votre et
pig lot
c'est une espèce de petit clapet qui
empêche les aliments d'aller dans les
poumons et l'air d'aller dans l'estomac
pour forcer le barrage rentrée de la le
manteau est contracté le coup en faisant
cette grimace
vous avez senti agressé passer direct
dans le 5ème temps 3 on expulse solaire
sortez votre menton de votre cou
redresser la tête ouvrait la bouche
relaxez-vous au maximum ça va sortir
tous
e
alors attention dans lequel la voix zoo
fabienne ça fait du bruit la leyre ne
descend pas aussi bas il reste juste au
niveau de la zone âge on le fait sortir
pour prononcer quelques syllabes qui on
reprend un peu d'air et on répète
l'opération pour finir sa phrase
et ça sent pas mauvais du club l'air
extérieur et que ça descend pas jusqu'à
l'estomac mais si vous êtes dans la
performance vraiment la compétition avec
des amis je vais vous donner mon petit
truc perso
il faut avaler de l'air plusieurs fois
d'affilée pour un maximum de puissance
mais attention pas trop quand sinon vous
risquez d'être sévèrement ballonné et
parfois ça pique
[Musique]
voilà détester c'est fini pour
aujourd'hui on se retrouve très vite
pour une nouvelle vidéo
en attendant prenez soin de vous prenez
soin des autres et surtout portez vous
bien
[Musique]